now as they prepared to vote for a
resolution of contempt against Attorney
General Bill Barr Democrats on the House
Judiciary Committee revealed themselves
once again it's a depressing and yet
very illuminating spectacle for our
country to see elected officials acting
like meth dealers because after
relentlessly pushing Russian collusion
for two years they were finally busted
no collusion and no obstruction but
Democrats refused to accept reality and
instead they continued to sell their
poison to scandal addicts on the left
the collusion part of the Muller report
recounts the constant interaction of
Trump operatives with Russian
adversaries if you think there's no
collusion and no obstruction you haven't
read the Muller report mr. Trump gets on
the telephone with mr. Putin and has a
90 minute conversation or something like
that
where he can see on a phone call that he
smiled at him that's your leader the
commander in chief oh yeah you're gonna
win the presidency with that line now to
keep the high going Democrats hold out
bill bar 2-time Attorney General as
their new nemesis and then they create a
phony conflict that's focused on a
narrow set of redactions in the Muller
report and on bars refusal to testify
again on the hill after Democrats change
the rules for his questioning this is
all part of a cover-up
we have lawful responsibilities
constitutional responsibilities too to
engage in one of which is possibly
impeachment how can we impeach without
getting the document and so I ask my
colleagues on the other side to stop
obscure faith ops you kidding that is
very hard to say that's not fair
all right Barr wasn't ever legally
required to release the full report to
Congress we forget that nor is he
legally allowed to release certain
redacted parts of it the Democrats know
that
now most of them on the committee are
lawyers well maybe they passed a
different type of bar exam I don't know
Bar has been over backwards in an effort
to accommodate Democrats and to be
transparent but none of that matters
because this is all theater it's all
choreography it's wrapped up in a bogus
concern about congressional oversight
this obstruction means the end of
congressional oversight were afraid of
the loss of the power of Congress to be
an independent and co-equal branch of
government I liked him better with the
the chicken when he was holding the
chicken now Democrats have all they need
to do their constitutional oversight
Muller spent two years and thirty
million dollars producing the report so
if the Democrats really want to impeach
the president they should convene
hearings tomorrow Democrats have been
given the option by the DOJ to read
everything but a very minimally redacted
copy of the Mullah report but guess what
none of them have actually gone to
review it or read it over at the DOJ
tells you all you need to know but after
winning a majority in November
Democrats remember Democrats promising
results and focus Democrats pledged
again a new majority hour for the people
agenda lower health care costs lower
prescription drugs bigger paychecks
building the infrastructure clean up
corruption to make America work for the
American bench people's interest
nothing special interest what do they
have to show the American people nothing
I think it was a maybe the ranking
member said we should be doing
legislation and how many signatures how
many bills have been signed into law by
this committee well ask Mitch McConnell
who has declared that the Senate is a
graveyard for all legislation that comes
from the house we have passed
outstanding legislation out of this
committee it's gone to the graveyard
more excuses more blame
shifting from chicken man more Russia
hysteria no attempt to work with
Republicans on the border crisis or much
of anything now they may have voted to
hold the Attorney General in contempt
today but what they really did is to
hold you the American people in contempt
savvy er than Democrats obviously think
they are I think most working people
they just want government to function
properly and to stay out of their lives
and if two recent polls are any
indication the American people are
letting the Democrats know where they
stand on the economy a recent CNN poll
showed that 56 percent of Americans
approved with the president's handling
of the economy that's a new high and the
most recent Gallup poll conducted almost
entirely in the weeks following the
Mullah report showed that Trump is
enjoying his highest approval yet in
their survey at 46% at the same time in
his presidency
well Barack Obama was at 44% I seem to
remember that he actually won rejas his
re-election so what's the real
motivation here on the part of the
Democrats congressman Jordan nailed it
today I don't think today is actually
about getting information I don't think
it's about getting the unredacted Mullah
report I don't think last week's hearing
was actually about having staff question
the Attorney General it's all about
trying to destroy bill bar because
Democrats are nervous he's going to get
to the bottom of everything he's gonna
find out how and why this investigation
started in the first place what can be
done to a president can be done to any
of us and this committee is supposed to
look out for that fundamental fact more
than anything else and we are not doing
that today
exactly right and given Congress's
Congress's most recent approval numbers
I'd say the American people have held
them in contempt for a long long time
and that's the angle